waise tumhe yaadein aaj kya hai?
How to say today?
badkismati se aaj meri tumse shaadi ho gayi thi.
tum bhi na, mazak karna kab chhodoge?
चलो मैं आफिस के लिए लेट हो रहा हूँ.
Are Saab, kaisi rahi hai Goa ki trip?
kaun gaya goa?
Last week you went?
pagal hai kya? kuch bhi bole ja raha hai.
You arrived?
pata nahi cart ko kya ho gaya?
keh raha hai pichhle hafte main goa gaya tha.
main kaise cheezein bol sakta hoon?
But you had gone.
tum bhi pagal ho gayi ho kya?
arey yaar, bata nahin sab pagal ho gaya hai.
keh rahe hain assuming Goa gaya tha.
Tu pichle hafte Goa gaya tha?
Tu bhi pagal hogaya kya?
See, your Goa photos.
tumne mere jeene ki azaadi chheen rakhi thi.
humne thoda sa paisa kya maang liya tha?
tumne to mujhe apna ghulam samajh liya.
Galat to mere sath bhi bahut kuch hua hai.
so we all together made a plan to play with your mind.
aur tum haar gaye.
to hame badla ho gaya na pada.